When President Biden announced his vaccine mandate
plan in September, Gallup reported that roughly six
in ten adults favored the requirements for federal
government workers, employees of large companies,
and workers at hospitals. 58% of employed people
in Gallup's September polling supported their
employer requiring employees without a medical
exemption to get the jab, while 36% were opposed.
In an early October Axios/Ipsos poll, 27% said
their employer was requiring them to get one,
up from 16% in August. Americans believe their
fellow citizens should make the choice themselves
about getting a vaccine. An August USA Today/Ipsos
poll found that 72% percent of Americans agreed
that people have a right not to get the vaccine.
At the same time, 70% said that unvaccinated people
should not expect to be around vaccinated people.
65% said the unvaccinated should be barred from
large events, and separately, from traveling by
plane. At this time, most Americans don't see the
vaccine as an infringement on personal liberty.
Do you think Americans should be required to get the covid vaccine? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like andsubscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.